wäre es ja um 17 Uhr 30 soweit wir
senden jetzt eine kurze vor ortsendung
und werden in dieser vorerzählung des
ZDF Programm auf das phönix-programm
Schalten denn in Berlin wird der große
Zapfenstreich erwartet das ist die
höchste militärische Zeremonie die es
gibt und die wird normalerweise nur für
bundeskanzlerinnen wir haben ja zuletzt
einen Zapfenstreich für Angela Merkel
miterlebt oder für Präsidenten oder für
verteidigungsministerinnen
geselebriert heute Abend gibt es in also
für Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer als
verteilungsministerin hat AKK einiges
angestoßen scheiterte aber oft einen
Umständen und dazu fiel das Ende des
Afghanistan einsetztes in ihrer Amtszeit
und nun zieht sie sich aus der Politik
und auch aus dem Bundestag zurück
in wenigen Minuten beginnt hier im
Berliner Bezirk Tiergarten der große
Zapfenstreich unter anderem im Beisein
von bundesaußenministerin Anna Lena
baerborg und etwa 250 Ehrengästen auf
der Tribüne
ja und damit guten Abend liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer herzlich
willkommen zu diesem ZDF Spezial knapp
zwei Wochen nach dem Zapfenstreich für
Angela Merkel und so ist es Brauch wird
also auch die Bundesministerin der
Verteidigung mit höchsten militärischen
Ehren verabschiedet auch Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer hat sich drei
Musikstücke gewünscht die vom
staatsmusikchor der Bundeswehr gleich zu
Gehör gebracht werden aber bis es soweit
ist schauen wir noch mal zurück auf eine
zweijährige Amtszeit die vor allem vom
Abzug der deutschen Soldaten aus
Afghanistan geprägt war Thomas Reichert
zieht Bilanz
eigentlich hatte Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer ist ausgeschlossen
neben dem cdu-parteivorsitz auch
Ministerin zu werden im Juli 2019 war
Begriff sie doch zu als ihre Vorgängerin
von der Leyen zur Präsidentin der
EU-Kommission gewählt wurde
damals Maxi gehofft haben ihre eigene
Position zu verbessern im random Merkels
Nachfolge um die Kanzlerkandidatur
AKK übernahm ein Ministerium in
politischen Unwettern in dem das
Verhältnis zwischen Truppe und
politischer Führung tief gestört war sie
brachte einen anderen einen
verständnisvolleren Ton mit setzte sich
ein für eine bessere Ausstattung der
Soldatinnen und Soldaten und erreichte
deutliche Steigerung des
Verteidigungsbudgets die Probleme
allerdings blieben
gegen rechtsextreme Umtriebe bei der
Eliteeinheit KSK wollte AKK ursprünglich
mit einem eisernen Besen Vorgehen die
Schlussfolgerung aus der Analyse heißt
dass das KSK in seiner jetzigen
Verfassung so nicht bestehen bleiben
kann dass es von innen heraus verändert
werden muss
soweit kam es nicht nur eine Kompanie
wurde aufgelöst der ksk-kommandeur
ausgewechselt und eine strengere
Aufsicht eingeführt
AKK sah Deutschland den Westen im System
Wettstreit mit Diktaturen wie China
gegen Merkels Vorbehalte versuchte sie
mit der Bundeswehr Zeichen zu setzen
schickte die Fregatte Bayern in den
Indopazifik wo China und die USA um die
vorerschaft Ringen
das ist wirklich ein Zeichen für die
regelbasierte Ordnung für die Freiheit
für die Freiheit von Schifffahrt von der
wir als Exportnation abhängig sind und
auf profitieren doch als Ende Juni nach
20 Jahren die letzten Truppen aus
Afghanistan zurückkehrten waren wieder
Merkel noch AKK da um sie zu empfangen
sodass ich doch als ihr Kommandeur für
Sie feststellen müssen komplett die
Mission aber war gerade nicht
abgeschlossen die Taliban übernahm die
Macht in Afghanistan schneller als AKK
und alle anderen in der Regierung
erwartet hatten es dauerte lange bis
Deutschland begann jene zu evakuieren
die Not geraten die der Bundeswehr in
Afghanistan über Jahre geholfen hatten
am Ende gelang es nur zum Teil die
Rückkehr der evakuierungstruppen war
bittersüß viele gerettet noch mehr
zurückgelassen für AKK war es ein Moment
großer Erleichterung von dem dieses Bild
diese Umarmung blieb
AKK war gern Verteidigungsministerin und
wäre es gern geblieben nun verlässt sie
das Ministerium und die Berliner Bühne
ja aber einen Termin hat sie noch keinen
unwichtigen nämlich ihre eigene
militärische Verabschiedung vom Amt der
bundesverteidigungsministerin hier auf
dem sogenannten Paradeplatz am Berliner
wendlerblock anwesend auch ihr Ehemann
und die beiden erwachsenen Kinder auch
einige Bundesminister haben sich
angekündigt Marco Buschmann wenn wir
vorne auf der linken Seite nächste
bundesaußenministerin wer Bock und
natürlich Weggefährten auch aus ihrer
saarländischen Zeit denn sie war ja
lange Ministerpräsidentin des Saarlandes
wir sehen eine
2g+-veranstaltung genesen geimpft und
zusätzlich getestet müssen die
Ehrengäste hier an diesem Mittwoch vor
dem Bendlerblock sein und das gibt uns
Gelegenheit mit einem Experten noch
einmal die Amtszeit von AKK Revue
passieren zu lassen nämlich Professor
söhnt geneizil von der Universität
Potsdam ich grüße sie Gott zum Gusse wir
haben gerade im Beitrag noch mal ein
Bild gesehen das vielleicht am meisten
in Erinnerung bleiben wird dass ihre hat
nämlich ganz zum Schluss Ende August als
sie dem Brigadegeneral der gerade aus
Afghanistan zurückgekehrt war quasi um
den Hals viel wie beliebt war AKK bei
der Truppe also sie war sehr eine sehr
beliebte Ministerin sie hat es geschafft
die Vertrauenskrise die doch herrschte
zwischen politischer Führung und Truppe
als sie das Amt übernommen hat 2016 die
doch halbwegs zu kippen sind sie sehr
beliebt gewesen sie hat eine gute
Tonalität in die Truppe gebracht und ja
viele bedauern das jetzt dass sie geht
und stellen sich natürlich dann auf die
neuer Ministerin ein schauen wir mal
soll es auch bedauern dass sie dieses
Amt ja nach nur knapp zweieinhalb Jahren
wieder abgeben muss und zwar an ihre
Nachfolgerin namens Christine Lamprecht
von der SPD beide haben vor genau einer
Woche ja auch hier die Amtsgeschäfte
einander übergeben auf der rechten Seite
also Christine Lambrecht begleitet vom
Generalinspektor der Bundeswehr Eberhard
Zorn dem wichtigsten dem höchsten
militärischen Berater der die
Bundesregierung kann man sagen ja und
das Christine Lambrecht dieses Ressort
übernimmt dürfte sie mit am meisten
überrascht haben nach 22 Jahren im
Deutschen Bundestag wollte sie sich
eigentlich aus der Politik verabschieden
und dann zu Preis ist man
Verteidigungsminister ist ein
anspruchsvolles Amt nicht nur ein großes
Haus zu führen sondern eben auch ein
sehr großer nachgeordneter Bereich und
das ist sicherlich nicht ganz einfach
wenn man da relativ unbelastet durch
Vorwissen hineinkommt diesen Bereich zu
verstehen aber man muss jedem Minister
hier der Ministerin eine Chance geben
und warten wir ab wie Frau Lamprecht
sich in diesem in diesem Amt einführen
wird über die Herausforderungen in
diesem Amt und es sind zahlreiche wenn
man sicher im Laufe der Sendung noch
sprechen jetzt aber neben die drei
Persönlichkeiten zunächst einmal
Aufstellung auf diesem kleinen niedrigen
hohen Podest um den Großen Zapfenstreich
abzunehmen der jetzt in diesem Minuten
beginnen wird allem voran das
Wachbataillon des Bundesministeriums der
Verteidigung
stabsmusikchor der Bundeswehr das diesen
Zapfenstreich musikalisch umrahmen wird
und in der ersten Reihe die Fackelträger
die die Szenerie hier festlich
illuminieren
professionalzel was sind das für
Einheiten und die unterscheiden die sich
die Soldaten sind etwa 300 an der Zahl
die diesen großen Zapfenstreich
gestalten werden von anderen verwenden
in der Bundeswehr also das Wachbataillon
existiert seit 1957 und ist vorgesehen
für den protokollarischen Dienst
trainieren auch entsprechend für den
fotografischen Dienst aber man darf
nicht vergessen in einem Ernstfall
müssten sie das regierungsmittel
schützen das sind auch ausgebildet als
Soldaten aber vor allen Dingen natürlich
das Protokoll von daher unterscheidet
sich ja Dienst natürlich sehr von denen
andere Soldaten
sie tragen also nicht nur Fackeln und
Trompeten sondern wenn es ernst gewesen
würde auch Gewehre und müssten auch
kämpfen schauen wir vielleicht übrigens
die Musik dass der frische Marsch von
Ludwig van Beethoven der vorgeschriebene
einzugsmarsch eines jeden Großen
Zapfenstreichs und in der Tat dieses
Zeremoniell folgt eigentlich immer der
gleichen Abfolge dem gleichen Ablauf
seit 1922 also 1922 mit der
Nationalhymne dann ist das praktisch
gleich geblieben also ein militärisches
Zeremoniell mit langer Geschichte die
Wurzeln reichen bis in 16 Jahrhundert
zurück aber das was wir in den nächsten
40 Minuten erleben werden ist nicht ganz
so alt 19 Jahrhundert 1813 dann 18 30er
Jahre also frühestens 19
[Musik]
und dann in der absoluten Form seit 1922
in dieser Form
[Musik]
rechts und links
ihre Positionen ein heute in den
Uniformen der Marine wie überhaupt das
Wachbataillon hier in den Uniformen
aller drei fallstahlkräfte
[Musik]
die Kommandos die wir gerade schon
gehört haben von Oberstleutnant Kai
beinkel dem Bataillonskommandeur seit
2018 in dieser Funktion und ein
ausgebildeter Fallschirmjäger
und links
großer Zapfenstreich richtig
Augen gerade aus
Fackelträger
das Gewehr über
Achtung präsentiert das
zur Meldung Augen rechts
Frau Ministerin ich melde großer
Zapfenstreich zu ihren Ehren angetreten
Frau Ministerin anders sich das großen
Zapfenstreiches zu ihren Ehren
überreiche ich ihn die Urkunde des
nachbarlös beim Bundesministerium der
Verteidigung
und genau wie die scheidende
Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel vor zwei
Wochen bekommt nun also auch Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer als aus dem Amt
schadende Bundesministerin der
Verteidigung die Urkunde des
Wachbataillons das Wachbataillon 1957
bereits gegründet
jahrzehntelang in Siegburg stationiert
aber seit 2014 hier in Berlin
das Gewehr über
Gewähr
großer Zapfenstreich
Serenade
von nun also die Serenade Annegret
kramparrenbauer hat sich drei
Musikstücke gewünscht als erstes die
Hymne der Bundeswehr wir dienen
Deutschland von Simon Theissen
komponiert eine Hymne die alle
Teilstreitkräfte und Betätigungsfelder
der Bundeswehr widerspiegeln soll
[Musik]
ja ein emotionales Stück Programmmusik
das wohl nicht zufällig wie Filmmusik
klingt und bei Werbespots auch bei
Imagefilmen der Bundeswehr eingesetzt
wird ein musikalischer Fingerabdruck ja
und dem Volk im zweiten Teil der
Serenade ein Hauch von Hollywood könnte
man sagen es folgt nämlich die
Titelmusik aus dem Western Klassiker die
glorreichen Sieben bemännliches in seven
von 1960 ein Stück das sich Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer gewünscht hat und mit
dem sie sich bei ihren engsten
Mitarbeitern bedanken
[Musik]
ja man sieht Jill Brunner horst Buchholz
Steve McQueen förmlich durch die
präriereiten bei diesem Titel dem
Klassiker aus den glorreichen Sieben der
Begriffe sind seven der zweite
Musikwunsch von Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer auch dieser musste in
den letzten Tagen eigens einstudiert
werden vom stabsmusikchor der Bundeswehr
und nun bleiben wir amerikanisch mit
einem Soul Titel von Jackie Wilson mit
dem sich die aus dem Amt geschiedene
Verteidigungsministerin bei ihrer
eigenen Familie bedanken möchte your
love keeps lifting me higher and hire
[Musik]
der Soul Titel your love keeps lifting
me higher and higher von Jackie Wilson
und damit folgt AKK einer ja
gewissermaßen Tradition auch ihrer
Vorgänger und Vorgängerinnen in dem Amt
die sich eben zum Großen Zapfenstreich
zur Verabschiedung nicht immer nur
Marschmusik gewünscht haben sondern eben
auch modernere Titel ja die Serenade ist
beendet und nun beginnt der eigentliche
Große Zapfenstreich mit dem locken dem
preußischen zapfenstreichmarsch der
sogenannten retrett und dem
musikalischen Gebet mit dem dann der
große Zapfenstreich abschließt
großer Zapfenstreich
und mit diesem Kommando beginnt der Kern
des Großen Zapfenstreichs dem locken
durch den Spielmannszug dieses locken
erinnert an die trommelsignale die den
bevorstehenden Zapfen Streich im
Feldlager angekündigt haben wird nun von
den Spielleuten also Spielmanns Trommel
und Pfeife unter Leitung des
tambur-majors ausgeführt
und damit beginnt gleich der erste Teil
dieses zeremoniens
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ja und dem locken durch Spielmanns
Trommel und Pfeife folgt nun der
preußische zapfenstreichmarsch als
traditionelement der Fußtruppen
[Musik]
der preußische zapfenstreichmarsch als
Element der Fußtruppen und nun beginnt
die retrett mit drei Posten also
Fanfaren rufen als Tradition der
britenen Truppen diese drei Posten
zeichnen sich durch eine zunehmende
Getragenheit aus und rufen symbolisch
nacheinander die versprengten und die
Verwundeten nach der Schlacht zurück
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja und diesem dritten und letzten
Fanfaren Ruf als Gruß an die gefallenen
Soldaten die nicht mehr zurückkehren
schließt sich nun hier beim Großen
Zapfenstreich für Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer ein religiöser Teil an
es handelt sich um eine koralstrophe die
später mit dem Text ich bete an die
Macht der Liebe unterlegt wurde und das
Gebet beginnt mit dem Zeichen zum Gebet
durch den Spielmannszug
[Musik]
der Spielmannszug mit dem Zeichen zum
Gebet das war übrigens der preußische
König Friedrich Wilhelm III der 1813
während der napoleonischen
Befreiungskriege angeordnet hatte nach
russischem Vorbild dem Zapfenstreich ein
Gebet hinzuzufügen und zum ersten Mal
ist die Zeremonie in ihrer heutigen Form
1838 hier in Berlin aufgeführt worden
zur Ehren damals des russischen Zaren
Nikolaus des ersten seitdem gehört eben
auch das Gebet zum festen Bestandteil
dieses Zeremoniells
ab zum
Gebet
ja der Helm wird jetzt mit der linken
Hand vor die Brust gehalten und nun ich
bete an die Macht der Liebe die Melodie
stammt vom ukrainischen Komponisten
Dimitri depanovic
[Musik]
das stabsmusikor der Bundeswehr unter
der Leitung von Reinhard kiauka mit sich
bete an die Macht der Liebe der Choral
wird regelmäßig als Bestandteil des
Zapfenstreichs gespielt außer übrigens
in Bayern wo das bayerische
Militärgebiet aufgeführt wird
nun dürfen die Soldatinnen und Soldaten
die Angehörigen des Wachbataillons ihre
Helme wieder aufsetzen ja ich bete an
die Macht der Liebe das ist ein
religiöses Element bei einem
militärischen Zeremoniell das Marktkauf
den einen oder anderen befremdlich
wirken ist aber eben gemeint als
Einladung zur Andacht für alle
Glaubensgemeinschaften und Aufforderung
zufrieden und Toleranz
es folgt nun das Abschlagen nach dem
Gebet und der Ruf nach dem Gebet und
dieser Ruf knüpft musikalisch an die
retrette an die wir eben gehört haben
und umrahmt so den ganzen Gebetsteil
[Musik]
und nun also folgt die deutsche
Nationalhymne seit 1922 endet damit
immer der große Zapfenstreich
[Musik]
zur Meldung Augen
ich melde den Großen Zapfenstreich ab
Augen gerade aus
das Gewehr über
Gewehr
rechts und links
ja mit diesen Kommandos von
Bataillonskommandeur Kai beinkel geht
ein Zeremoniell zu Ende dessen Wurzeln
fast 500 Jahre alt sind bis in 16
jahrhundert zurückreichen in die Zeit
der Landsknechte wenn die damals ins
Lager zurückkehren sollten dagegen ein
Offizier begleitet von einem Pfeiffer
oder auch Trommler durch die Gaststuben
und schlug mit seinem Stock auf den
Zapfen des Fasses danach durfte der wird
keine Getränke mehr ausgeben die
Soldaten mussten ihre Zelte ja und
diesen Befehl landen die Landsknechte
damals Zapfenstreich wer sich eben
wieder setzte wurde ziemlich hart
bestraft
[Musik]
das Gewehr
rechts
großer Zapfenstreich
boah
[Musik]
und zu den Klängen des rollst du schon
zapfenstreichmarsches den wir vorhin
schon gehört haben marschiert die
Formation das Wachbataillon beim
Bundesministerium der Verteidigung der
staatsmusikkore und die zwei Züge
Begleitkommando die Fackelträger also
aus verlassen den Paradeplatz hier vor
dem Berliner metzler-block aber nicht
ohne vorher noch einmal an der Personen
vorbei zum Marschieren die vor
eineinhalb Jahre lang ihre oberste Bild
Herren war Inhaberin der Befehl von
Kommando Gewalt nämlich Annegret
kramparrenbauert die mit ihrem großen
Tattoos zeichnen feierlich
verabschiedet
[Musik]
ja Professor kneitzel wir sehen Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer die jetzt bei den
letzten Blick werfen darf auf die
Soldaten für diese lange ah ja
zweieinhalb Jahre Verantwortung getragen
hat insgesamt 182.000 Soldaten der
Bundeswehr und die Nachfolgerin
Christine Lamprecht steht sozusagen in
den Startlöchern ist jetzt seit genau 7
Tagen im Amt was sind aus ihrer Sicht
die größten Aufgaben die größten
Herausforderungen die jetzt nach
zweieinhalb Jahren AKK auf Christine
Landkreis warten ja das sind ganz viele
Herausforderungen ich glaube das ist
Frau Landrecht zunächst die Rüstung in
Griff bekommen muss und insgesamt muss
man sicherlich leider sagen dass die
Bundeswehr dysfunktional organisiert und
ich glaube das auch die Krisen die
international und ich glaube das ist die
Kraft einer einzelnen Ministerin
übersteigt die Bundeswehr wirklich fit
zu machen für die Herausforderungen die
vor uns fliegen und ich glaube das ist
eine Aufgabe des ganzen Kabinetts also
es wird darauf ankommen wie weit auch
vor Landrechte Unterstützung des
Kanzlers zum Beispiel dafür bekommt und
das war glaube ich auch das von Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer das eine Ministerin
alleine diese reformaufgaben nicht
stemmen kann es hängt immer auch vom
Kanzler da kanzlerinnen die selbst hat
ja bereits eine Reform des
Beschaffungswesens in der Bundeswehr
angekündigt es gibt aber noch
vielfältige andere Probleme wenn man
denke allein daran dass tausende
Dienstposten in der Bundeswehr unbesetzt
sind Jetpiloten Bienen Taucher
Sanitätsoffiziere woran liegt das
eigentlich mangelt es an Geld oder an
einer Geldmangel das nicht die
Bundeswehr hat glaube ich genug Geld sie
ist einfach in Ihrer Organisation zu
Ineffizienz und dann ist sie natürlich
muss sie konkurrieren mit dem
Arbeitsmarkt also gerade die technischen
Berufe ist mangelt glaube ich nicht an
Infanteristen aber eben an
Elektrotechnikern die Flugzeuge waren
und dergleichen das ist eine
Herausforderung für Berufsarmeen also da
steht sehr viel an und letztlich die
Frage was wollen wir mit der Bundeswehr
diese Frage ist eine gesellschaftliche
Frage die auch die gesamte Politik
beantworten muss nicht nur eine
Ministerin und früher war die Frage
relativ leicht beantwortet die
Bundeswehr diente der landesver Bewegung
heute steht sie im Ausland Afghanistan
ist abgeschlossen aber eine andere große
Einsatz für die in Mali mit zwei
UN-Missionen mit über 3.000
Herausforderungen natürlich jetzt auch
die bündnisverteidigung Stichwort
ukraine-konflikt aber auch solche
Hybriden Bedrohungen wie Cyber stehen an
also die Bundeswehr hat eine
Aufgabenfeld das viel vielfältiger ist
als früher die beiden Ministerinnen noch
einmal im Gespräch vor einer Woche bei
der Amtsübergabe und das hat ein
bisschen für Irritationen gesorgt war ja
AKK nicht öffentlich aufgetreten beide
hatten allerdings versichert dass sie in
einem vertraulichen vier augengespräch
die Amtsgeschäfte übergeben hat und nun
also dass sie noch einmal mit einem
Blumenstrauß in der Hand von den rund
250 Ehrengästen hier auf der
Ehrentribüne auf dem Paradeplatz des
pendlerblocks verabschiedet neben ihr
Mann Helmut ja und für sie für Akku
beginnt nun eine Zeit von der man nicht
so ganz genau weiß wohin sie führt sie
kamen aus dem Saarland gegen nach Berlin
der hat auf sagt man da verzichtet
glauben Sie das sozusagen ihre
politische Laufbahn zumindest in der
Hauptstadt beendet ist das ist dieser
Ausflug nach Berlin der 2018 begannen
ist als Generalsekretärin
Parteivorsitzenden Ministerin der
scheint jetzt beendet und ich finde es
einfach eigentlich
einen guten Zug dann auch des Bundestags
von dort jüngeren Abgeordneten zu
überlassen jedes jeder Moment hat seine
Zeit und sie klebt nicht am Amt und sie
klebt nicht an den Mandaten und jetzt
sind wir mal gespannt was aus Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer wird nicht ob sie sich
ins Private zurückzieht ob sie noch mal
andere
Ämter übernimmt schauen wir mal aber ich
finde es ist ein souveräner Abgang der
Beginn von Christine Lambrecht im Amt
war direkt geprägt durch einen
tragischen Unfall auf dem
Truppenübungsplatz in Bergen bei ihrer
Ansprache hier vor einer Woche hat
Lamprecht auch gesagt dieser Vorfall
zeige ihr ja die Massivität der
Verantwortung die sie nun trägt für
insgesamt 260.000
Angehörige Soldaten und bin Angestellter
und man ist eben als
Verteidigungsminister Inhaber der
befehls- und Kommando Gewalt wie das so
heißt und zumindest der de Maiziere
davon mal deutlich gemacht damals das
ist was besonderes ist eben kein
Ministeramt ich sage mal so wie jedes
andere auch wenn man im zweifelsäule die
Leute eben auch in die Einsätze schickt
mit Tod umgehen muss an den Sergen steht
und das sind besondere Verantwortung
hier es ist kein Ministerium wie jedes
andere und nun werden die Ministerin die
außer Dienst befindliche Christine
Lamprecht wie ich sehe steht aber noch
da sind also verlässt AKK die bis
letzten Mittwoch zumindest die
geschäftsführende Ministerin war
oberste
Inhaberin der befehls- und Kommando
Gewalt bis letzten Mittwoch verlässt und
also mit der Wagenkolonne hier das
Grundstück den Paradeplatz am zweiten
Dienst Sitz des
Bundesverteidigungsministeriums denn der
Hauptsitz befindet sich ja nach wie vor
auf der Bonner Hardhöhe und wir sehen
Christine Lamprecht im Gespräch mit
Eberhard Zorn und dieser Mann kann man
wohl sagen wird für Sie in den nächsten
Monaten und Jahren eine wichtige Rolle
spielen sehr wichtig Herr Zorn erlebt ja
schon die zweite Verabschiedung er hat
auch schon von vor allem Frau von der
Leyen die Verabschiedung erlebt und es
wird interessant sein wie lange hat so
noch im Amt bleibt also er war ja
relativ eng mit Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer kam auch aus dem
Saarland und normalerweise ist es üblich
dass die generalinspektive bleiben aber
eine neue Ministerin hat kann natürlich
auch dann über den Ruhestand
entscheiden ohne Angabe von Gründen und
wir werden sehen wie die beiden
miteinander zurechtkommen Eberhard Zorne
sehr beliebt in der Truppe gilt als ein
sehr Feger generalinspekt und schauen
wir mal an ich war noch können wir nicht
sagen was Frau Landrecht vor hat
natürlich ihre Berater mitgebracht aber
normalerweise bleiben die generell
bleibt die Generalität eigentlich im Amt
und sie muss sich auf diese Fachleute
natürlich dann auch verlassen wir sind
sehr gespannt auf das auf die Amtszeit
von Christine Lambrecht wie sie gesagt
haben für manche einen ist dieses Amt
auch ein steuersitz gewesen sie selber
wollte ihre politische Laufbahn beenden
und ist nun in diesem wichtigen Ressort
gelandet professionell danke für ihre
Expertise und ihren Besuch hier am
Berliner Bendlerblock ja liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer der große
Zapfenstreich geht zu Ende die Arbeit
aber die fängt jetzt erst richtig an für
die neue Ministerin für die Bundeswehr
aber auch für die Gesellschaft in deren
Mitte die Bundeswehr gehören sollte
danke für Ihr Interesse und wir
verabschieden uns aus dem kühlen Berlin
mit den Bildern des Tages
[Musik]
Vulkanausbrüche
Brände Überschwemmungen
Pandemie
Stürme und andere Katastrophen bedrohen
unsere zivil